russian opposition leader alexei navalny
is back
in russia and back in court he was
detained last night in moscow
after five months in germany recovering
from a poisoning attempt that nearly
killed him
the u.s and other countries are
demanding his release charlie dagetta
has new developments
in the navalny case
this morning alexi navalny called his
court hearing in moscow a
mockery the highest level of lawlessness
of justice
last night he stepped off the plane in
moscow right into the arms of a russian
police force welcoming committee
one kiss goodbye to his wife yulia
before being whisked away
he would have known the obvious risks
yet on board he said it was his best day
in five
months because he was going home his
detainment drew
immediate international condemnation
including from u.s secretary of state
mike pompeo who in a statement demanded
navalny's
immediate and unconditional release that
his detention
is the latest in a series of attempts to
silence navalny
and other opposition figures
[Music]
the kremlin's fiercest critic became
violently ill on a domestic flight five
months ago
he was airlifted in a coma to berlin
where toxicology reports confirmed he'd
been poisoned
with the novichok nerve agent in an
interview with cbs 60 minutes leslie
stahl
he laid blame directly on the russian
president himself
you have said you think that mr putin is
responsible
i don't think i'm sure that he's
responsible
the kremlin has denied any involvement
and say he's been detained for violating
parole terms from a previous suspended
sentence
whether he expected to be arrested or
not navali's return home
is seen as a direct challenge to the man
he blames
for his attempted murder for cbs this
morning
charlie dagetta london i'm very worried
for him you know
anthony you lived in moscow how can this
have a happy ending when he knows
that they want him dead well people want
him some people want him dead
alexander has been has been fearless
from the beginning
he has always been willing to get
directly in putin's face
it's an incredibly courageous act what
he's done i it's remarkable
but i think he feels he can only lead
the opposition from inside the country
not from outside
okay i hope it turns out okay for him